حيث اوقف هذه بورشنسكي هي قريه صغيره في
ضواحيها العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف هنا تماما
سقط صاروخ روسي في هذا المنزل او همم ما
تبقى من المنزل او الذي كان منزلا هنا
الذي دمر هنا بشكل كامل كما تشاهد في
الصوره امامك عمال النظافه الان يعملون
على نظافه الطريق امام هذه المنازل التي
دمرت بشكل كبير جر هذا القص هذا هو المنزل
الذي كان يعيش فيه اربعه اشخاص طبعا
لسخريه القدر خالتها هؤلاء الاشخاص هم من
النازحين من مدينه ماريوبل الذين لجاوا
الى كيف اظن منهم طبعا الوضع سيكون امن
ولكن طبعا لحقت بهم الصواريخ الروسيه حتى
هنا حتى الان لا احد يعلم من الجيران اذا
كانوا كانوا موجودين في المنزل العامله
عمال الانقاذ والدفاع
عفوا همم
ايضا الدفاع في رفع الانقاض والبحث عن
ضحايا لم يجدوا في هذا المنزل حتى الان
ضحيه
هذا المنزل الذي امامك الان في الشاشه هذا
هو المنزل الذي اصيب فيه ثلاثه اشخاص الجد
والابنه والحفيده ونقلوا الى المستشفى
لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه كما تتابع امامك
ايضا المنزل دمر بشكل كبير الان هنا
المواطنين يعني يتحدثون عن الاماكن التي
يمكن ان يلجا اليها او الاقارب الذين لا
يمكن ان يلجاوا اليهم خاصه ان درجات
الحراره منخفضه جدا والوضع همم طبعا صعب
جدا وانقطاع الكهرباء الوضع في العاصمه
40% من المدينه هي خارج تغطيه شبكه
الكهرباء تم اطلاق اربعه 64 صاروخا همم
نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه المختلفه في
اوديسا بروجا هكذا في سومي وميكا لايف
وحتى الغرب الاوكراني في الفيف وكذلك في
مدينه الشير نيجر همم
اه طبعا احنا في السلطات الاوكرانيه عن
الدعم هؤلاء المواطنين او البحث او او
توفير السكن بديل له ايضا حتى تتم صيانه
هذه المنازل او استعاده منازل بهم